hey what's up this is john with the dr
john dolone show i hope you're doing
well
hope your neighbors and you are getting
along hope you're being kind to the
people
all around you hope you're at work
hope your family's doing well i hope
everything is going okay
today we've got a special episode i'm
gonna
interview a nashville legend
miss [ __ ] gough she is the director of
child and adolescent counseling at day
star counseling here in nashville
tennessee she's been counseling kids
for 30 years and one of the things i
love to do when i sit down to talk to
mental health professionals
is i like to pretend that i'm asking
them questions for you guys
i like to pretend i'm asking them these
big global theoretical practical
questions
for others but reality i'm just asking
questions because i'm just a fumbling
dad trying to figure this out myself and
i got two little kids
i'm married i got two dogs running
around i've got neighbors i'm trying to
figure this out too
and so on the special edition i'm
talking to [ __ ] gough
about raising daughters raising sons how
to be married
amidst all this chaos what do you say to
your kid when they come to you and ask
you what racism is what covet 19 means
why can't we hang out what about
politics how do we navigate these messy
messy issues with little ones
we're so glad you're with us stay tuned
okay
so we were just talking off um offline
tell me about your practice here in
nashville
so we see kids from about four up
through 18
and we have individual counseling we
have group counseling
and then we have in the summer we have
um two different kind of summer programs
ones like
day camp and then we have an overnight
retreat program too for the kids that
are involved
and how many how many families are you
running through there 1900
currently a year well no just right now
in our practice we're seeing 1900
families holy so you'll roll
you'll rotate out yeah yeah thousands
yeah yes and i've been doing it almost
30 years so i don't even know how many
thousands
you're not even 30 years old there's no
way no way
thank you yes okay so
one of my favorite things about sitting
down with mental health professionals
is i like to ask veiled questions about
your expertise
about my own kids and family so i can
sound like i'm speaking to the masses
when really i'm trying to just steal
insights from you
and that i can take back to my own house
and that's makes me happy you've got the
same expertise
no you got 38. no i don't have this
i wish i wish so your most recent book
brave a teen's
girl's guide to beating worry and
anxiety tell me about the origin of this
so well pre-coveted i our publisher
actually based on another book called
are my kids on track came to me and said
will you write a book on anxiety for
little girls and you
would totally get this i was like not
unless i can write one for parents too
yes it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
right so i wrote
pre-covered one for elementary age girls
because that's the average age of onset
these days
and one for parents and then the
pandemic started
and all of a sudden i wasn't as worried
about the little girls but i was worried
about teenagers and so at that point i
thought i need to write one for them too
and so i cranked out the spray book in
like 10 weeks good for you
because you know we were home and kind
of bored at that point the most common
question i'm asked
above and beyond any other question is
what has happened in the last 25 years
that has made
everyone so anxious and depressed and
i've got my own theories and
whatever about it if you had to walk
back you start i mean
you've been in practice five years and
all of a sudden you watch stuff to start
to turn underneath us right
where would you point a mom and her dad
who's just sitting there with their face
in their hands
where would you point them to some of
the origins of this madness
well i mean you know genetically if a
parent you have anxiety your kids are
seven times more likely
and then i think technology is a huge
piece of it just what it does to our
brains
in terms of almost mimicking a state of
anxiety social media is a huge part of
it
i also really believe well and i read i
read
i love trying to graciously
yes yes yeah i read 23 books on anxiety
to get ready so i did a lot of research
and
the two most common parenting strategies
are escape and avoidance so the child
feels
concerned or worried and the parent
pulls them out yes
and i think that's making the problem
worse and part of it i think you're a
lot younger than i am but part of it i
think is
we grew up and our parents weren't in
counseling no
of course we weren't even talking about
any of these things and likely i mean i
wouldn't
my age group wasn't in counseling yours
might have been more
maybe i know and so i think we're seeing
a lot of parents who are
overcompensating for what they feel like
they didn't get and so now they're
trying so hard to understand and
empathize
that they're stopping there and the in
the books that have it broken down into
understanding health and hope okay
and it's like they're doing a great job
with the understanding but not moving
them into help and the coping sk
skills to work through it and so they
end up blazing this trail ahead of them
so that their kids will be okay totally
yes which then robs them of the ability
to learn some of these skills
right exactly yeah and in the books i
came up with this definition that
anxiety is an overestimation of the
problem
and an underestimation of themselves ah
okay so it's that gap between what i can
do and what i think i need to be doing
totally and when we rescue them we're
saying yep it's too big and you're too
small
so then they they run up against the
next thing and they immediately start
looking around for who's gonna
pluck them out right right okay so i
have a five-year-old girl and is she
your oldest
she's my youngest she's your anxious
i've got two okay so yeah um she's my
youngest i got a ten-year-old
boy and a five-year-old girl that's fun
it's super fun and
i my wife and i my wife's was
she graduated her phd before me we we
were so
so arrogant after our son like after a
couple years we just thought everyone
else sucks at parenting
we're geniuses clearly we need to quit
our jobs and go
teach people how to do this and then my
daughter came along and we realized we
have no idea what we were doing
right we just rolled the dice well on
the first round
what should i be doing now what can i be
doing this is me
not professional this is me coming to
you humbly
what can i be doing right now to make
sure
or to at least put some bread crumbs
along the way so that my daughter
can have as good a body image as good a
reflection image as possible i've heard
everything from it's the
it's the dad's responsibility to make
sure
your daughter grows up healthy i've
heard that it's that all she will do is
watch my wife's
um the way my wife um
processes her own image and she'll i've
heard everything in between
tell me something like or something a
few things i can do right now
to instill that in here well i don't
know that i would say i wouldn't
probably land in either place the older
i get the less black and white i am yeah
so i mean i think i think to think about
food as fuel okay obviously to
talk about strength instead of ever
talking about weight
i mean i i have so many i've had so many
moms over the years who are critical of
their daughter's bodies and i have never
i mean i jokingly say i've never had a
girl who says
my mom told me i need to lose some
weight and she says let me get on that
you know
you love her it backfires every time
and so i think as a dad i mean i think
i definitely think it's great to tell
her she's beautiful inside and out that
you're talking about
all of where beauty comes from in her
and that it's really resonating
inside of her more than anything and
that flows outward but i think too
you as a dad have this i think as women
were so intense
and i think as men you have this ability
to have a light-heartedness
and help them move toward risk-taking in
a way that is
challenging but in a playful tone okay
and so i think when she learns that
she's capable
and strong and she can step into things
with you that are out of her comfort
zone i think
that capability and competence are i
think
linked to self-image and even body image
i think it all
just runs together yes yes so i think
speaking to the strengths of who she
is and helping grow her confidence and
an ability
in a way that's very unique to who you
are as a man how do you
grow a kid's confidence besides
letting them try and fail
it seems to be the the link right yeah
cause i can't i can't just tell them
right but but you do that too right i
mean i think it's both i mean they're
gonna roll their eyes and she's gonna
say you have to say that because you're
my dad
but i would say say it anyway okay you
know i one of my i have a friend who is
really confident probably one of the
most confident women i know and we were
at a dinner party one time and she said
that when she was growing up every time
she walked down the stairs of her home
like every time no matter how she was
dressed her dad whistled the theme song
to miss america
oh wow isn't that awesome which i mean
she was never in a pageant in her whole
life but i love that he was saying
when you walk in the room i'm going to
stop and pay attention to you yup
and i think just that level of
engagement even
plays into her confidence in a really
significant way and that's not
taking her on some elaborate date no
it's just the little things yeah
i notice that my kids it from
however different they are they both if
i were to distill
them down into one sentence it one one
question it would be
please see me and that seems to be the
most pervasive
overarching thing about their behavior
whether my son is trying to get straight
a's my daughter's trying to set
something on fire or vice versa right
it is please see me right and if i every
time i can jump the front of the line
and make sure they know before they even
have to
perform yeah i see you just because
you're you right
it just seems that the air in the room
gets lighter right
um okay so one of the things you wrote
about in your book which i love
and you remember i made my nerd heart
feel good
um you talk about this idea of
co-rumination right
so we talk a lot about on this show this
idea of rumination this idea is just
it's just spinning and spinning and we
think that we are
thinking about important things and so
we give ourselves a pass
right so we'll sit there and have
imaginary conversations that we're never
going to have
yes right we flex like in a toughness
that we
absolutely are not right but we're
thinking about hard things about when
the world's gonna end and how much
bullets we're gonna have all the stuff
right yes
non-productive thinking yeah but then
you get into co-rumination
in this balance between i
we have a dance right where i just spend
all my time telling you how bad things
are and you
give me an audience right how do i
balance that in my kids
right because i want them to be heard
and i want them to be listened to and i
think one of the worst things
men do is we run in and try to give
facts based solutions to everything
instead of just being with right and
listening how do i both hear
and avoid that co-rumination cycle it's
just such a mess
mm-hmm you know i think
where i think it can be i love to think
about marriage counseling 101 you know
the first time you ever go to marriage
counseling and one of the first things
you learn to do is reflective listening
yep what i hear you saying is and it
sounds so silly
stop solving you listen yeah yeah yeah
right and i mean i remember being in
graduate school when they taught that
and me thinking that's not going to do a
thing and then all of a sudden it's
magical
yeah when you do it and so i think no
matter what age your kids are
to be able to say back i really hear
that you're frustrated or i get that
you're worried about that or
i understand i mean seeing them and
saying it back to them
and then i'm a huge fan i always just
talk about empathy and questions
sometimes that's the only thing i'll say
to a parent in a whole session so
being empathetic and then moving towards
what do you want to do about it what do
you feel like god's called you to do in
this who do you want to be in this
because i think when we're fixing it for
them when we're problem solving for them
we're going back to that definition of
anxiety
not only can you not do it you can't
even figure it out and so i've got to do
it for you
but when we come back with questions
empathy and then questions we're saying
i think you're capable like you got this
so there's that
i live by two creeds one you don't need
to say anything to your kids because
they're watching you
if you want to live a certain way you
have to live it because they're watching
you
yes and the second is let them know that
they're seen
but that takes out my core defense
mechanism which is my advice
right right so i
i want everyone listening to this to
hear someone way smarter than me
on most occasions the last thing your
kids need is
advice your advice yes how do you teach
a parent to shut up
to just stop talking you like how i did
that i pointed it to parents being the
listener
that was good you know i mean
what i will do in my counseling office
is say i met with
a couple recently and they're repeating
the same thing over and over and over
especially with adolescents by you
by the time you hit that point they've
heard everything you have to say all of
it
and so i said to this couple have has
she heard you say that before and they
said yes and then i said then stop
singing
what she needs now is for you to feel
like she likes you
yes just shut up
my sister and i have a joke my dad was a
homicide it was a swat hostage
negotiator
so he got people off a build right wow
and
we have this fireplace in our old
childhood home where my dad would sit in
one recliner and my mom
and and i've told the story publicly so
they won't be embarrassed and
they would talk to us and we know how
many bricks were in the fireplace
because we'd heard it yes we knew you
just glanced and you glazed over right
and it was that idea of being talked at
versus talked with right or heard yeah
yes okay all right so this is
maybe a messier question since
uh we know the kids watch you right
give me the universal husband here some
tips on how
i can love my wife how can i
love my partner enough in ways that my
daughter
and even my son will pick that up right
because i want
her not to have a frontal lobe
understanding of what love is but i
wanted to see it
what are some things that couples get
wrong when it comes to loving each other
in a way that's demonstrative well i
think with girls
in particular girls are so intuitive
from a really early age
and they start to pick up on the
differences in your parenting and they
start to manipulate it
so good and so i feel like one of the
best things we can do for girls
is to present a unified front okay over
the years i've had way too many
stories of things like i remember a girl
sitting in my office and saying to me
well my mom's really strict
and my dad and i think which
however yeah it's scary already yeah
they're like investing in counseling
already or marriage counseling maybe for
her later
and so i think enjoying your wife
presenting a unified front i mean of
course you're gonna have disagreements
but
arguments need to have behind be had
behind closed doors
and i would recommend two sets of closed
doors because girls listen
i mean i hear so many girls talking
about sitting at the top of the stairs
and listening to their parents argue
downstairs you know
so i think those are probably two of the
best things so i've i've gotten advice
in the past
to argue in front of your kids not and
not wildly
so that they can see an arc of a
relationship
where this is what a disagreement of
between two people who love each other
and then the next morning they're having
breakfast together and everybody's
smiling laughing
that must be what that looks like right
yes what's the balance between that
i guess that's the balance between that
disagreement versus a
we need to get behind closed doors take
gloves off for me yes really angry
and i think specifically if it's about
them
because what will happen is if it's
about them one of you is often going to
be
siding with your child and feeling like
the other parent is being too strict
and so when that happens that's where i
think girls can step into all that freud
stuff
they start owning yeah you yes i'm going
to triangulate myself in here between my
parents
and so i think those are the arguments
that feel more concerning to me
as primarily counselor to girls that
they're going to start to work that
later on
is it true that um i hope it's true
because i say it almost every single
show whatever it is um
that you you alluded to this kids feel
the ten the relational tension yes and
they tend to backfill that tension with
it must be my fault
and they start trying to solve it in
these ways is that right
yes absolutely okay yeah and they start
solving it
it's been my experience that kids
whether they get into stuff that we've
all said
is not a good idea whether it's they're
gonna run off and make straight a's
they're gonna tuck their shirts in
and they're gonna try to perfect their
body image that really
on the ark is the same behavior it just
we we reward some of it unfortunately
and then it can still pathologize itself
we can still get off the rails there
and then we go to war against other
behaviors but really
they're just trying to i guess it goes
back to being seen but they're just
trying to perform right yes
absolutely and i mean that's you know
with anxiety right now girls are leading
the statistics
and boys are taken in for treatment more
whereas girls are more anxious and i
think it's because of exactly what you
said i think
boys often are more explosive and so
we're seeing their behavior and it's
concerning and girls who are anxious
they're imploding from the inside out
and they're perfectionistic and they're
doing
great in school and parent-teacher
conferences the teachers say i wish
every child was like her
but we're missing that it's fueled by
the same thing this panic inside of i've
got to live up to the expectations
so how do you man you're going to get me
all fired up here and it's
just the day so how what do i say as a
parent
i know my daughter's not doing well and
the teacher is saying
i you know you can feel your your seven
year old your 12 year old your 14 year
old start to withdraw
yeah they're still they're still
checking the boxes
right they're going to school they're
still getting the grades good enough
you know you're losing your kid and you
can't put your finger on it and you got
a teacher you got a
a pastor at some church you've got
adults in their soccer coach saying
i would do anything for for a team full
of those right and then i got
a a boy who's a knucklehead and
rambunctious
and so kind and so compassionate and i
you can watch them grinding through that
distraction to get their grades
and i've got a teacher saying i don't
want that kid in my class anymore what
how do you how do you equip what would
you equip parents with
to go into those conversations well i
think
i would say trust your gut as a parent
because you're going to have a million
people you see that she's making me look
so
smart oh my gosh
dude this is this is this whole episode
everybody's just for me
it's 100 for me i have a low self-esteem
and she's making me feel better
yes okay yeah i mean i you know your
child better than anybody
and and i think just like with our
health you've got to advocate for
yourself
and for your child and so even if it
takes you saying things and putting
yourself out there and going back over
and over
trust your gut and follow it so as
someone who's works with families
a lot how many times do you have your
own kids
no okay you don't okay i've counseled
thousands of them over the years but i
have a two-year-old nephew
okay so how would you answer this
question for me then
the longer i go the more i wish i could
walk back
that makes sense how do you teach a
parent to forgive themselves how about
that
the more i i go oh gosh i wish i could
have that conversation back or
oh and freaking i wish i could how do
you not let that pile up as a parent
and you can begin to discharge that
that pain and then move on right you
can't keep carrying that around with you
well i mean i think it all gets used
at some point and if
this generation of kids is feeling more
pressure than ever before to be a
perfect parent
the fact that you weren't is only going
to help them
alleviate that when they get to their
own parenting and i think
you know again you're younger than i am
but i think so many of us never had
parents who said i'm sorry will you
forgive me
and and they kids today feel so much
pressure to be
perfect and so as their hero for you to
say to them
i blew it i'm sorry will you forgive me
even if it's five years later i've been
thinking about a conversation we had
once
and i wish i'd done that differently
like what a powerful message for them
that validates who values them i think
saying i'm sorry to your kids is the
most important you can do is that fair
yes absolutely it's fair yes
i think anybody apologizes to anybody
these days is pretty awesome yes
and failing in front of him yeah you
know they say man it blew that way yes
and come with me as i go make it right
yes so good at what point
um let me just back up this year was
a mess we all experienced it yes
our kids experienced it and every single
parent i know from a parent of
four-year-olds to parents of 24 year
olds
had to navigate how much do i tell my
kid
when do i tell them what do i tell them
how much do i shield them from hide them
from etc
um what what insights do you give to
parents when they are navigating
how much of these issues covet george
floyd racism stuff
and politics how much of that
how do you teach a parent to navigate
that well the first thing i would say is
you always want to be the source
as their parents in all things they need
to feel like they know
where you are on things and that they
can come to you with anything and so
when we avoid
topics i think we take ourselves out of
being the source a lot of times
and so i would say start young
especially if you feel like they've
heard about it somewhere else and give
them really
short just less than a paragraph of
information
gotcha you know hey here's we have this
pandemic that started in our world tell
me what you've heard
i mean i would immediately go back to
them and let them
tell you because often they haven't
heard much or
they've heard something wacky at school
that's so off yeah
accurate and i think so many times we
end up having those conversations out of
our own panic
and so we give them more information
than they even need but it's about us
and it's not about them
yes i've got to offload this instead of
totally so i would say a little bit then
tell me what you've heard and then
ask me questions and then that way again
they're kind of leading
because they i mean in all things even
if we were talking about parents getting
divorced
kids ask the questions that they're
ready for the information
and if they don't ask they can't handle
it a lot of times okay so
those would be my main things i would
say in terms of
and it's been my experience that you if
you
are going to engage in a kid you got to
tell the truth yes absolutely
i've just seen too many folks round
about the truth or lie to their kids or
skip over stuff and then suddenly 5 10
secrets always come out
secrets always come out they always come
out yeah i'd rather
hard things come out and my kid no my
dad's an idiot but he tells the truth
versus
right my dad lied to me right i would
much rather this over that
yes so
what's the what's what's the one thing
as a parent i gotta know
me and my wife are sitting there looking
at our two kids running around the yard
tell us what we need to know right now
well
[ __ ] goff help me i i
think we would probably as a staff at
day star
collectively say that we have had more
parents in our offices in tears
in the last six months than we've ever
had
have experienced that too yeah and so i
would say
number one you're doing great listening
you're doing great
with your kids whatever is going on with
them that just the fact that you're here
and showing up and trying
right now in 2021 means you're doing
great we gave josephine cigarettes for
the first time she got super calm
last night and i'm gonna tell my wife
that's not great are you doing
great yeah i think that's one thing i
would say and then
you know the other thing as i was
reading writing the first two books on
anxiety it was pre-pandemic and one of
the things i was worried about
is how i felt like kids were less
resilient than they had been
in generations and i think we were part
of it like all those
living my best life t-shirts and hashtag
best day ever all that stuff which by
the way i haven't heard in a year
nope but i think we were making it worse
because they felt like something's wrong
with me
because i'm going through something hard
and i
firmly believe the kids growing up right
now are going to be more resilient than
kids
that we've seen in generations by 100 i
think there's so much hope
yeah i've even seen some preliminary
studies that
kids are have adapted especially young
kids
to usually there's a focus on mouths
when you're talking to and they're
already being able to shift and
recognize i
crinkles it so quick and so some of
these things i was so
freaked out about may end up not coming
to right and not coming to pass and it
ends up being my drama that i'm
i'm passing on to my kids then as
opposed to them me trying to protect
them in any noble way or whatever so
all right so [ __ ] goth child
counselor extraordinaire thank you for
sure about time you're so awesome
there's a few people that come through
here um that
everyone is saying oh they're a great
person that you should interview
and my kids go there right so it's this
isn't like uh
uh like a high-level referral or this is
like no this is where my colleagues put
their
put their money and put their most
trusted resource so these two books
extraordinary where can people go get
these anywhere books are sold and we
have a
web web we have a website that's raising
boys and girls dot com excellent raising
boys and girls dot com
[ __ ] golf if you have a child i was
gonna say if you have a child struggling
with anxiety
and i'm just gonna refine that if you
have a child you should pick up these
two books
um thank you so much for your time here
to be here and i hope you guys
keep doing the great great work that
y'all are in our community
thank you so much hey thank you so much
for joining me and my new friend
[ __ ] gough if you're interested in her
books if you've got kids that are
struggling with anxiety
if you've got daughters who are
struggling with anxiety check out the
show notes
and we will list the resources there i
hope everybody in your life is doing
well
we're not going to have any lyrics today
we're just going to end it here
thank you for joining us with the dr
john dalone show
you